my ultimate Italian lunch I'm cooking
scrummy sardines topped with a fragrant
gremolata dressing but first a
deliciously fresh orzo pasta salad
this is one of the hidden delicacies of
Italian pasta orzo because 90% of the
time it's always hidden in a soup or
broth or minestrone and it looks like
large grains of rice but once they
absorb that water they double in size
it's a pasta that needs a lot of help
seasoned it nicely pinch of salt a
splash of extra-virgin olive oil fresh
bay leaf into the boiling water and that
bay leaf really helps the flavor the
pasta good it'll pan a turn left and
right that stops any pasta sticking to
the bottom and the secret behind cooking
any pasta is having a nice gentle
rolling boil you just have the gas up
where the outside of the pan is just
rolling and all that orzo is tumbling
over each other
gently boiling pasta rapidly tends to
destroy the outside texture it doesn't
take the marinade or the vinaigrette
with the sauce for the dressing Parmesan
twist of fresh pepper zest of the lemon
squeeze your lemon in there throw your
fingers to catch all those seeds bring
that together with some extra virgin
olive oil pine nuts taste delicious and
toasting them just elevates them after
eight minutes my orzo is perfectly al
dente train it nobody cold water so it
flows the cooking process down but stops
me going mushy it's the size of pumpkin
seeds now a drizzle of olive oil into
the vinaigrette
whilst it's still warm just above room
temperature because the wall with a
pasta the more absorbs the vinaigrette
and now some texture rocket not finely
chopped
by the fresh basil as well roll them up
like a big fat cigar slice in half and
they chop the basil crunch just sprinkle
the toasted pine nuts it looks like a
plate of jewels listens is it delicious
a fragrant orzo past the sellers now the
sardines incredibly healthy
absolutely delicious grilled never ever
be intimidated on looking for fresh fish
it's about the condition of the fish
bright eyes Fresh Kills nice bright red
interior and the firmness of the flesh
almost you could stand the fish up on
his own it needs to be that fresh the
best way to get flavor into sardine is
to grill it light seasoning live or just
roll the seasoning around get your
rosemary peel off a few of the little
shards at the answers a little bit sharp
push the rosemary hint almost like
you're threading makes them so much more
flavor something
they'll be scared those fine little
bones I remember growing up with
sardines tinned sardines you didn't tell
your nose up at the boat once the
griddle pan starts to smoke lightly
drizzle and then sardines on
to half of three minutes each side now
for the gremolata a vinaigrette that
sits beautifully well on the sardines
freshly fastly just one the knife once
nothing worse when you over chopped
parsley and elect delicious flavors left
on the board possessed the juice of an
orange and a lemon
turn them now grandma loves us about
fragrance natural flavors brilliant of
grilled meats as well
don't touch a salt and pepper and then
olive oil just to bring it together a
guy like I almost want to be like secret
weapon in their rate it bring that
together you've got a very fresh clean
gremolata almost if we sat on the Amalfi
Coast
oh then wash the sardines are still nice
and warm and just thinly coat the
gremolata
I'd like the path in the garlic to sit
on top and a citrus from the lemon and
the orange to sort of dive underneath
you see why Italian cuisine rides on the
freshest and the simplest execution they
allow their ingredients to become the
hero not the chef orzo salad with
stunning grilled sardines
wherever you eat this dish it will fill
your senses with the Sun and the sea of
the Mediterranean delicious
[Music]